so drea is it fair to for me to say that
you are the advantage queen of survivor
42
yes
okay
okay you get that title
and that was a wild tribal council and
i'm you've had time to process it how
are you feeling today now that all is
said and done
i feel good i feel like a release i feel
like
i played the best game that i could play
i did the the survivor thing and i'm
great i'm proud of it you should be i
think that you there's a lot that you
accomplished while you were out there
and you went out in a memorable way and
going back to that tribal council when
you played your knowledge's power
advantage were you confident that mike
had his idol and how did it feel when
you found out that he had given it away
believe it or not i wasn't that
confident that he did like um
i knew that they were all after me since
episode 2 i was just fighting for my
life so
i knew that it was a chance that i could
take and i was going to take it i wasn't
that confident
and then i knew like if it didn't go
through
i would go up there and i'd play my two
boats and see and hope
that someone else understands that mike
needs to go home
no i love that you went out and you were
like i have an arsenal of advantages and
i'm using them all
exactly
i'm not leaving anything in my bag
that's how you have to do it all right
and during the tribal council you said
that you're very observant and that
you're always watching so was there
something that happened in the days
leading up to your vote that tipped you
off to know that you might be in trouble
i knew that
taku was closer than we thought
uh they were starting to reveal it a bit
more
i knew that
lindsay was really close to mike and uh
i knew that mike was close to jonathan
and i knew that they all tried to get me
out to tribals beforehand
so i knew that
ultimately i was probably going to be by
myself and that
if
lindsay was safe
it would be me regardless of whoever
else they tell me so i was fully aware
of that yeah
okay so speaking of the taku tribe
we had some questions from fans on
twitter and kalafro on twitter asked was
omar your number one on the tribe and
what made you decide to share the
information about your knowledge's power
with him
you know what
i related to omar on a very personal
level in this game
like he was one of the first people i
talked to post that tribal about
our similarities and his sisters and
stuff like it was like a personal
relationship so like people don't
understand how close
i thought
i was with omar
and
it was starting to get out there that he
was a strategic player
so for me it was just like we need to
have each other's back because
eventually if it's not me it's going to
be you
and
this is not the time to go at each other
right now so like in a time where you
can't trust anyone
you actually do have to hope that you
can trust someone
and i was still talking to romeo and
they didn't show this but there was a
part where i was talking to romeo and
like i know they're coming after me he's
like yeah they are and i was just like i
want to trust omar i feel like i can
like we like
really close and then romeo's like i
feel like you can trust omar and like
when i had that confidence like that
that
romeo tell me that who i considered
someone who wouldn't lie to me
i was like okay i can't choose one more
so it was really like romeo's stamp of
approval that i went to go have that
conversation over hoping that like
see that we need to trust each other to
go farther in this game and we can like
go out at the end but not right now it's
not the time
well i actually want to also ask you
about your relationship with romeo
because it looks like when you were
starting the game you both had a really
good relationship can you tell me about
how the relationship evolved over the
course of the game
yeah like romeo was my number one and
ika
and then we
went to merge and
he just kind of faded
he was
hungry and cranky and
not talking to people and
i was building relationships because
that's what you need to do when you get
to march camp and i was building
relationships and they would ask me who
my number one and number two were and i
would tell them romeo and rox but they
weren't really understanding because
romeo
wasn't doing anything to to help his
game play he's actually hurting my
gameplay more than
than helping my game play
and there'll be numerous times where i
take romeo's fight and say romeo you go
talk to people like
start making friends and he's like
they're not talking to me and i'm like
this isn't like uh
like you need to just go make friends
like help me help you you know like
there's only so much i can do and
and then it just started getting weird
because he was talking to tori more than
he was talking to me and everyone at
that camp knew that tory wanted me out
so then
i had to get smart and when i said that
at that tribal like my mother would tell
me like you don't know these i was
talking to romeo i'm like i can't keep
on like fighting for you and helping you
and you're not believing me like we
really only know each other for like 20
days you know like
at some point i'm gonna have to let you
go because you're hurting my gameplay
so that's what happened but
at the end of the day i love romeo and
even
to my advice i still trusted him
yeah so
that's what happened
okay well i also want to ask because i
feel like you were great in tribal
council you were always being very
upfront about how you were feeling so
your exit i think was so lively and you
shared some great information as you
were leaving so first
you told mike if he made it to the end
he'd probably win so what was your
motivation for saying this in that
moment
i wanted people to realize that
mike
is a very likable person
um
and that
it's probably not in your best interest
to keep him going because he's not
burning bridges
even the way that we left
he left me going into the jury liking
him it's a likable person
so like get smart you know um so that's
why i said that i love mike but it was
just like
come on
who keeps the firemen in the game
come on i know
well on the flip side you also use this
as an opportunity to really out omar for
telling people about the the information
you gave him about the knowledge is
power so what were you also trying to
achieve with
sharing information about omar
omar played a good strategic game but
his strategy was like an emotional game
like he got close to us on a personal
level and
to the point where we never thought that
he would even use these things against
us so i wanted people to know that like
he got close to me enough for me to
trust him with this and him only
with this information so be aware that
like he uses that trust
against you
so that was why i did that like open
your eyes
play
i feel like at least the audience heard
your message loud and clear so i'm
excited to see whatever happens
um
and i i think that you and i share a
bond knowing that we're folks who live
in canada who went and played survivor i
think that that's always going to be so
special so what was it like for you to
be able to represent montreal when you
were out there playing
it was crazy i was the first montrealer
to ever play
survivor how crazy is that
um
i wanted to come out strong i wanted to
play hard i wanted to
represent my city as hard as i could and
and go out with the bang in a festive
way as montrealers do
yeah i feel like i did that i feel like
i went out a true montrealer way you
know so i'm proud of that and
hopefully i'll be i have to do it again
oh yeah oh people will will remember it
for sure
um so now you're on the jury you get to
sit back watch the game play and then
you get to make the decision at the end
of the game for who you want to vote for
to win so as a jury member what are you
looking for in the winner of survivor 42
um
game play
i want game play like i want
to know what you did what were your
moves um
even if i wasn't previewed to it
tell me
how did you make big moves in this game
like explain to me i'm i really just
want to know that
um
it's a game that i respect
it's a game again
and uh i want the best player to play
awesome i mean in terms of a respectable
game i know that you played one you are
the advantage queen of survivor 42 you
were the richest advantage person of the
season so congratulations it was thank
you for watching you drea and i wish you
all of the best thank you for chatting
thanks erica
you